beauté des paysages gentillesse de la
population ciel bleu assurer 20 degrés
en moyenne l'hiver d'octobre à avril
le maroc est devenu la destination
privilégiée des amateurs de camping cars
ils arrivent de toute l'europe
[Musique]
à 27 km d'agadir entre atlantique et
montagne une ville semblent sortis de
terre c'est le plus grand camping du
maghreb avec 1000 camping car et plus de
2000 personnes retraités pour la plupart
ils reviennent d'une année sur l'autre y
prendre leurs quartiers d'hiver et
retrouver leurs habitudes et leurs amis
tout est prévu pour le confort des
résidents commerces restaurants cafés
boutiques de souvenirs et bien sûr tout
pour entretenir son camping-car
mécanicien ou stations de lavage même le
vendeur de tapis passe à domicile
[Musique]
rené 71 ans originaire de rennes est
soudeur à la retraite vit d'octobre à
mars au maroc depuis dix ans alors
j'avais une maison vous pouvoir écouter
tout élément du touret au coin du feu ou
pour 120 terrains paix d'amour dure
comme pour faire cheap et d'avant-hier l
aéroport etc sud à chacun paie ni carla
c'est un modèle qui va chercher à peu
près chanson coup de roue mais bon et
julia chapati kiroulbien il et c'est
bien par contre j'ai des modèles qui me
tue l'amour copains la ilaha caïla
camping-car qui évoluent en 5000 euro
bonds lui déjà l'appui de moyens mais
moi j'étais ouvrier un enfermement de la
maison d'accueil
sa part te ment mais la différence d'un
appartement je peux aller partout voilà
le camping est classé quatre étoiles
il en coûte 8 euros par jour avec un
tarif dégressif selon la durée du séjour
les allées portent les noms des grandes
villes marocaines elles suffiront à
faire voyager
ceux qui choisissent de ne pas en bouger
pendant des semaines car dans le petit
monde des camping caristes
il y a les sédentaires et les nomades
ceux qui décident de faire le tour du
maroc
ne s'arrêtant dans les campings que pour
se ravitailler et réviser le matériel à
rouen le groupe des nomades est prête à
quitter la normandie pour son long
voyage dernier rangement dans le
camping-car pour daniel et christiane
haute a rien oublié ta prière le plus le
pantalon le vin là on a tout ce qu'il
faut là on a des origines conserve
ouais il ya des poils et tout ça ici
[Musique]
comme ça c'est calais ça y est
robert et marie eux aussi de rouen ont
rendez vous chez daniel et christiane
ces jeunes retraités partent ensemble
pour le maroc pour la deuxième année
consécutive
le voyage de robert marie danielle et
christiane va durer deux mois
un périple de 9000 kilomètres pour
rejoindre le maroc en passant par les
routes de france et d'espagne
vous vous connaissez depuis combien de
temps tous les deux pas depuis l'année
dernière ce qui n'est plus maintenant on
s'est connus avec le club a continué de
voir montre deux fois dans le côté
pratique du corps militaire en même
temps c'est que voyager on se fait des
amis
voilà quoi ce qui me fait envie de
repartir c'est tout d'abord le soleil
parce que nos bons puis à ce petit côté
où ce qui n'est pas négligeable quand
même au niveau de d'aller passer ses
deux mois et demi trois mois au maroc
qui fait quand même une économie
substantielle au niveau de beaucoup de
choses
c'est à dire que là chez nous ballet
chauffage sont quasiment au ralenti en
hors gel et et puis il ya la
consommation d'électricité une gaz ou
très peu il n'y a pas d'eau où il n'a
pas commis substantielle que leur époque
est pas un et aurait pas que pas
négligeable
par la suite après bon ben il ya tout le
contest qui dit il ya l accueil accueil
à le climat il y a
la vie est moins chère c'est bon tout ça
quand on additionne tout ça c'est vrai
que ça prend davantage
les jeunes retraités ont tout leur temps
et pour éviter les péages
ils ont choisi les petites routes
j'aime bien peu c'est une itinérante
j'aime bien j'aime bien changer
d'endroit tous les jours se réveiller à
la mère un jour à la montagne jours la
campagne
et puis tous les joueurs se réveillent
avec un nouveau paysage au partant
darrois quatre départements du nord
ouest ou demain sur les côtés les
rafales pourraient partout atteindre
130km château d'ars fardeau pour 16 et 4
dents longues et pour des épreuves
phares aux formes marsan dax est
l'unique après deux jours de route et
une nuit passée sur le parking du centre
commercial de poitiers
les amis normands retrouve sur une aire
de repos à dax jacques michel venus de
la drôme et les ardéchois gérard et
michel première rencontre du groupe au
complet
c'est avec le concours de leurs
fédérations et d'internet que le contact
a pu s'établir pour les nouveaux venus
ce sera leur premier séjour au maroc on
vient chez mon frère donc plus
carcassonne laborde donc on a longé
pyrénées dit yasser un clocher j'ai pas
dormi de la nuit non quart d'heure trois
quarts d'heure tout le temps mais
laurent tu vois c'est cinq fois par jour
la prière et pendant cinq jours qui va
entendre le mot là là où avant de crier
dans ton peuple tu as tu vas dire la
partie à la prime et les amis ont
conseillé ces gens-là acquise en février
dernière c'est comme ça qu'ils avaient
ensemble et puis d'amis en ami et puis
il faut savoir que bien
iratchet il n'y a pas
dans les supers sont attendus tous au
même stade et puis voilà c'est ce que
rapporte deux compères en club
organisait il ya toi qui a fait ça c'est
que je ne pouvais je vais bientôt la
route demain donc je prendrai la tête
demain et parce que voilà et puis donc
et puis bon bah après en cours de route
on s'arrangera on verra pour le voir
discuter de notre itinéraire et puis
monde en quête toujours quelqu'un que
puisse se fait pas toujours le même qui
soyons en premier l'engouement pour le
camping charisme ne cesse de se vérifier
avec quatre mille clubs et associations
la france compte près de 600 mille
passionnés j'espère
[Applaudissements]
non
retour au camping les bâtiments réservés
aux douches lessive et autres vidange
sont le lieu des rencontres matinales
tous les jours serge le ch'ti 73 ans
ancien facteur est à la plonge
après des années de pratique il est même
devenu maniaque
il ya des leurs effets et il s ata de
brannens fondu tu vois c'est un grand
jour pour les hommes parce que tu as de
quoi vous dites voilà un bon petit coup
c'est pas pour celui qui les dérives et
voilà
moi je me repose honnêtement je me
repose j'ai des genoux classique j'ai
les prothèses autres pour être au marché
mais on a toujours quelque chose à faire
voilà la vaisselle grossesse et la
naissance il reproduit lit il ya les
cours sont décembre je vais acheter mon
poisson d'abord donc j'arrive à
connaître tout le monde ce que tout le
monde connaît le ch'timi là-bas la plage
comme j'arrive
c'est suite au film à ga tiab la ville
haute
c'est c'est resté comme joie
autre habitude matinale la visite au
port de pêche
juste à la sortie du camping rené a le
contact facile
il sait tout des pêcheurs et de leurs
métiers alors là nous arrivons dans un
petit port de pêche qui s'appelle omis
wada est là tous les pêcheurs qui rentre
de la mer vous allez pouvoir les voir
arriver
ils commencent à arriver tout le long
ici et après il est à leur passion sur
la plage et on peut choisir les patients
qu'on veut et et acheter
ils vont à quelques encablures dans la
mer ils peuvent pas être loin parce
qu'il n'ya pas de sécurité mais ils
tendent les filets tout le monde
la plage ils vont aller relever puis
viennent après
ilian tu veux acheter du faso
comment ça c'est tagro mulet ça et c'est
du beau bienvenue à y aller moi je dis
nous a réunis l'us open
[Musique]
robin
voilà
dans cet immense espace de 14 hectares
on se déplace à vélo et parfois même
avec des engins à moteur pour faire ses
courses ou se balader dans le camping
jean marc et marin et annick psycho
sophrologue
ils ont décidé de faire un break dans
leur vie professionnelle
ils viennent d'acquérir pour la modique
somme de 4000 euros
un camping-car qu'ils surnomment le
bigorneau parce que c'est le plus petit
du camping et parce qu'ils viennent de
bretagne
[Musique]
un plaisir pour les enfants
regarde la place il ya tout partout de
batteries avril traire un moteur terminé
l'essentiel je suis certainement
souhaité qu'on a eu peur que le bon sens
vol bon après est bien ici a tout ce
qu'il faut c'est petit mais là tout ce
qu'ils font alors hier on a mangé la
tajine au coin avec des olives
regardez c'est un petit peu c'est un
mini moi j'ai repeint ici parce que
c'était tout tristounet bhl se lever ici
bava alors on entoure également ici
alors c'est très propre à gauche très
propre en droit et ceux qui ont été
organisées et puis nouveau bond à
l'offre
la vaisselle c'est normal moi je fais la
popote et jean-marc j'avais celle qu'est
ce qu'un marin et une sophrologue fonds
au maroc en camping car on fait un break
alors ouais ça c'est ta maison parce que
m'auriez demandé ça et quelques mois je
vous avais dit hors de question que je
sois dans un engin comme ça pour moi ça
représente vraiment le ce qu'on appelait
le titre est très facilement le
le truc du beaufre total exactement
l'image que je voulais pas avoir et puis
en fait il ya cinq six mois de ça bon
c'est bien on cherchait à et puis et
puis on s'est dit on teste mois ouais
alors on est passé par les montagnes on
a eu de la neige du vent de la pluie
enfin tous les tout toutes ces choses
qui font qu'on est bien dans un petit
endroit comme ça qu'ils sont petits
chauffages penser qu on est bien quoi et
jean-marc ne veut pas être en reste avec
ses voisins allemands un coup de balai
s'impose urgosse valladoid bolide
tous
les nomades viennent de passer la
frontière espagnole un arrêt obligatoire
pour les dernières provisions
c'est meilleur marché robert rappelle sa
marée anti gel
tous
pluie neige vivement le maroc en
attendant première nuit sur une aire de
repos
ce n'est peut-être pas très accueillant
mais il y a tout ce qu'il faut pour
l'entretien des camping cars
heureusement de partir comme ça déjà
j'ai besoin de travail déjà c'est vrai
qu'il est pas grand-chose à faire juste
faire à manger
du coup de bol ils puissent ayez
puissent se promener qu'à la maison est
toujours à faire toujours à faire la
maison on arrête moi j'arrête pas la
maison où vivent quelque chose à faire
que là bas ça me fait du bien je me
repose plus marcher ça fait du bien pour
voir le paysage est ou pas moi je suis
heureuse heureuse
gérard ne supporte pas la moindre trace
de boer ou de poussière sur son
camping-car haut de gamme
alors sans option ne lui fait 77 mille
euros et avec avec la suède coutelot
86000 chaque mois celle du haut de gamme
quoi disons parce que ça va radieuse
copie car proposer un concept 35000
euros jusqu'à des 129 200000 euros lit
king size écran plat et paraboles
deuxième couchage douche indépendante
gérard et michel sont très fiers de leur
luxueux camping car
deuxième nuit en espagne et aucun
camping en vue alors le parking d'une
usine désaffectée au bord d'une route à
quatre voies fera la faire la liberté ça
se mérite
chacun s'occupe ou commence à faire
connaissance avec le maroc protégés sur
son flanc ouest par une médaille par une
muraille asmo annezin almohades et sur
son flanc sud par le mur des andalous la
médina de rabat se distingue de la
kasbah des oudayas par l'activité
débordante de ses grandes artères
donc on a eu du mal et au hammam non oui
je pense est prévue c'est la première
fac et par tout un groupe
ces indépendants c'est la première fois
que nous partons en groupe
la première impression pour l'instant
sont bonnes on partage la même optique
donc visiter sans trop comment dirais-je
imposée est libre de manger soit
ensemble ou soit avec les collègues les
amis même là on va dire que c'est des
amis parce qu'ils sont tous bien sympa
du c'est un gros groupe on wii et 4 je
pense 4,5 si bien
[Musique]
bras daniel la chaussée
zoug et extérieur
il habite
en espagne comme en france interdit
d'utiliser son talkie-walkie au volant
pour l'avoir oublié
robert va écoper d'une amende de 105
euros payables sur le champ et en
liquide
je voudrais remercier tous mes amis
camping caristes qui se sont cotisés
pour payer l'amendé
ben voilà maintenant fera plus attention
quoi on on n'utilisera plus le tas qui
voile qui pour pouvoir discuter entre
nous quoi est ce que tu es restée trop
longtemps fait appeler sur un truc parce
que oui je jouais à la main la marie et
puis toi tu mords fils tu morphil
l'objet du délit
[Musique]
au camping c'est l'heure du déjeuner
venez c'est le roi du tajine
il prépare avec amour ce plat
traditionnel du maroc
quand même temps vous rester six mois on
entend que six mois tania qu'au départ
on croit en toi moi de de normal qu'on a
doit ré a confié une prolongation et la
prolongation mais il faut absolument
partie à moi il faut que je dois la
limite c'est le 11 avril
autrement c'est des catastrophes qui
risquent la prison
c'est à dire là bas tu es considéré
comme chez nous sans papiers voilà
et les autres six mois voulait passer ou
alors je m'en vais devoir en france voir
mes enfants je fais le dauphiné libéré
le vélo parce que j'adore le vélo je
fais pas de vélo mais j'adore les
courses je fais le tour de france avec
les couvreurs étape par étape les
utilisateurs irene et des âmes pas les
étapes de plat et après je repasse au
mois d'août en utilisant fort ou ceux
qui sont dans le midi ou qui dix ans
après je regrette je refais mon jeu peut
pas mauvais il faut partir avec le 10
octobre le voilà
pourquoi venir six mois ici et pour le
soleil parce que je sais pas si vous
êtes au courant mais a laissé trop bas 4
1 des gens présentés cette année c'est
possible c'est bon pour les rhumatismes
on n'attend pas cette année ça fait du
bien allez je prends des cachets si le
soleil la fois qu'il va plus et matthew
la bouteille l'habitude c'est ma femme
mon mari c'est beaucoup plus à sa place
moi et m'a remplacé un peu mais pas
boire un verre de monter une très grande
réussite
je souhaite a besoin de le faire parce
que on se soit pas vieillir moi j'ai 71
ans moi je sens pas bien lire au
comptoir beaucoup de différence des
différentes manga social a écrite en
italien il y at-il donc on se dit
bonjour c'est des petits gars sympa
qu'on retrouve pas beaucoup gêné c'est
fou c'est fou j'ai retrouvé ici en
dehors de chez moi
j'avais été dans le temps je vais tout
patron avançant donc on s'est quittés à
l'âge de 12 ans 13 ans à peu près j'ai
retrouvé ici plus de 50 ans il ya un
truc qui est vachement appréciable ici
c'est que les gens sont pas glissés sur
son agressif sont toujours bonne humeur
mécontents c'est plutôt là quoi si on
veut partir du 31 au départ et puis si
on veut partir pour un autre notre ville
à d'autres endroits sur la côte ou
reproduiront les malades ceux qui
pillent et des bagages s'amuse en
s'amusant voilà ses vignes et séville
algésiras josias los barrios
le rocher de gibraltar annonce la
frontière marocaine mauvaise surprise
pour le groupe en un an
le billet de passage en ferry a augmenté
de 150%
ce matin c'était la police espagnole et
aujourd'hui c'est la campagne et une
navigation
réveil matinal pour être parmi les
premiers à l'embarquement
une traversée de 45 minutes et après
cinq jours de route
enfin le maroc
[Musique]
mais la première étape sur le sol
marocain et sous la pluie viendra un peu
j'ai dit que le seul il arrive ce après
midi casablanca 16 degrés avec à tout
petit nuage noir et puis reste sept
bleus 19 marrakech donc on va l'avoir
ça arrive
[Musique]
le mauvais temps n'empêche ni la balade
en barque pour admirer la faune ni la
visite du souk de moulay booth l'aiment
et surtout pas le couscous chez moment
aux sables d'or
[Musique]
troisième jour sur le sol marocain et
toujours pas de soleil
on se croirait un petit peu en normandie
enfin je crois qu'en france et pierre
aujourd'hui soit en rouge partout alors
donc on était mieux ici sera une lada
ont la chance d'avoir une température de
14 degrés au réveil quand même malgré la
pluie alors là on les aime boussalem
goulag du célèbre et là on descend sur
rabat dans la journée de demain on
descendra donc sur el jadida
après on prendra ses troupes là de st
jusqu'à sa fille
la pluie redouble 50 ans qui n'avait pas
autant plus dans le nord du maroc
mais à la sortie de kénitra à 200 km au
sud
les premières cigognes font leur
apparition annonçant l'arrivée du
printemps
[Musique]
le moral est revenu chez les nomades le
soleil est enfin de la partie
le groupe va poursuivre son tour du
maroc dernière halte au camping la les
jours se suivent et se ressemblent pour
le plus grand bonheur des sédentaires
[Musique]
pas besoin de bouger c'est tout le maroc
qui viennent à eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]